yeah being black definitely helps I
think everything's kind of heading
towards that kind of Ben Simmons kind of
trans sort of vibe where everybody's
gonna be I think a lot of people that's
what I said we've always said like beige
power like in three generations you
can't you're gonna need even now you
need like a chart to be racist I feel
like you need like a you know what I'm
saying you need to like carry the one if
you're really gonna get into it being
black and white is that that's got to be
like the [__] coolest I feel like but
is it scary sometimes like do you feel
black and white or do you just feel one
thing I feel like me like if you walk
past like a barbecue spot do you feel
like part of you comes to the edge of
your skin
and if you walk past like a um a cop do
you feel those same cells that kind of
move to the other 100 but the craziest
part is is like because here here's
here's a fact whether whether you
[__] like logic or not or whether
you're like whatever it's like for I
don't give a [__] I'm not here to argue
because you know there's people who's
like well you don't you'll never
understand what it's like to walk down
the street as a black man and I'm like
yo all right I want you to shut the [__]
up yeah because you'll never understand
what it's like to walk down the street
as a black man in a white man's body and
then wait wait let me Shut the [__] up
why are we arguing yeah you're like Mrs
Doubtfire but that's what I'm saying why
hello why are we arguing in the first
place what you what you're going through
I'm not denying what you're going
through [__] all that [__] so for me
it's like yeah it's a crazy thing like
yeah and I love it you know
[__] used to always be like oh
you he talks about this all the time I'm
like so the [__] what man I don't give a
[__] I'm proud I like it you know what I
mean you can look at [__]
Twitter bio and there should be like
black and proud [__] I'm
biracial I'm proud but I do feel I
definitely code switch a lot you
familiar with this term uh-uh code
switching is like if I was going into
like a [__] interview or some [__]
I'm like well hello there sir yes I'd
really like this job I I really
appreciate that thank you so much oh
excuse me I have one call [__] what the
[__] man you got my [__] what you know
what I mean so it's like that it is a
part of you it is almost like you kind
of feel like two like two different
people but that's one thing in the
culture as well it's like any anybody
who's of the culture who meets me IRL
not some [__] anybody who [__]
really meets me shakes my hand they know
what's up because it's not a thing why
would it even be a thing it's not a
thing it's only a thing on the internet
it's only anything on the internet like
I've never met anybody and they're like
no you're not you're not like because
it's not a thing
it's not a thing it's not a thing it's
like I definitely love to let people
know who I am
so yeah when I meet somebody if they're
like tell me about yourself first thing
out of my [__] mouth black dad white
Mom Dad I grew up broke it's just it's
it's my [__] identity this is who the
[__] I am [__] the internet I'm black I
told you
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one